problem number eighteen
a
teen
the average arithmetic mean of x and y
is k so the average so x plus y
over two is k right that's the average
of x and y is equal to k
which of the following is the average of
x y and z so they want to know what
x plus y
so the average of x y and z is you add
up all the numbers and divide by three
so we they want to know in terms of k
and z so let's just if we could
substitute for x plus y then we'd be
done
so multiplying this equation by two
we get
x plus y is equal to 2k right just
multiplied both sides by 2.
and then x plus y is 2k so let's just
substitute 2k here
for x plus y
so then you just get 2k
plus z
over 3 that's the average of x plus y x
y and z 2k plus z
and that is choice
2k plus z over 3 and that is choice a
choice a
problem 19
problem 19.
we have a neat
drawing here let me see if i can
draw this
see we have a circle
circle
and then we have a triangle inside of
that so well it's not really inside of
it it's kind of does something like
see the triangle goes like that
then we have
i don't close enough i think you get the
point
it actually kind of touches at the
bottom there this is actually touching
at the bottom
and then we have oh we have another line
that goes
down like this
all right
okay
this is o
o
y x
w
z this is w
let me do a better color w okay o
v all right and the figure above
triangle x y z is equilateral good to
know with width side of length two so
this side is two this side is two and
this whole side is two
if wy is the diameter of the circle with
center o so wy this is the diameter of
the circle with center o
then the area of the circle is
fascinating so essentially we just need
to figure out what the height of this
line is because if we know if we know
the length of this we can figure out the
area because that's the diameter we know
the area radius and we use pi r squared
so what's how do we figure that out
this is an equilateral triangle so that
means all of the sides are 60 degrees
all of the angles are 60 degrees so
that's 60
this is 60. degrees
and now this whole angle up here is
going to be 60 but we kind of we split
it exactly in 2
right
so this angle is going to be 30 degrees
and this angle is 30 degrees and if you
don't believe me how else do we know
that well they tell us that this is a
right angle right
this is a right angle this is a 90
degree angle so that's how we know this
was actually split into because this is
90 this is 60 they have to add up to 180
so this angle up here is 30.
so i think you are going to see now that
this is a classic
30-60-90 triangle
right
if this
if the side up here is 2
then we know that the side opposite the
30 degree side
is half the hypotenuse this side is the
hypotenuse right here the 30 degree side
up the corresponding side to the 30
degree center the opposite to the 30
degree side is half the hypotenuse if
this is 2 this is 1. and that also makes
sense because this is a symmetric
triangle and i mean this this kind of w
is the midpoint because we you know it's
perpendicular and these angles are the
same so this would also be one so one
and one and two one plus one is two so
that makes sense as well and then we
know and if you forget this they
actually give you the formula at the
beginning of every sat exam
that the side opposite the 60 degree
side which is the side we're trying to
figure out that that's square root of 3
times
this side so square root of 3 times this
is what well it's
it's it's square root of 3 times 1 which
is square root of 3. and if you don't
believe this you could kind of try the
pythagorean theorem right square root of
3 squared plus 1 squared
is equal to
well 3 plus 1 which is equal to 4 which
is equal to 2 squared which is equal to
2 squared which is equal to hypotenuse
squared so we figured out this diameter
right here square root of 3. the whole
thing is square root of 3.
now if we want if the whole thing is
square root of 3 what is the radius the
radius is going to be half of that
the radius is half of that so the radius
is square root of 3
over 2.
and now we're ready to figure out the
area area is equal to pi r squared and
they give you this formula too at the
beginning of the sct so area is equal to
pi
times square root of 3 over 2 squared
and that equals pi times square root of
3 squared is 3
over and then 2 squared is 4. so 3 4 pi
and that is choice
3 4 pi is choice c
choice c
image clear image invert colors all
right
problem 20.
where already end of this section
problem 20. when 15 is divided by
positive by the positive integer k the
remainder is 3. so 15 divided by k
has
remainder remainder
remainder three i'm lazy
how many different values
of k four how many different values of k
is this true
so when 15 is divided by k you have a
remainder
of three
interesting okay
so essentially
what ha well we could i mean the actual
easiest thing to do is
is say well 15 divided by
15 divided by k well is is going to be
essentially um
well the easiest way i'm just trying to
think of whether we should just do it by
brute force we can actually just do it
by brute force because
it says k is a positive integer right so
what values of k work well does k equal
1 work
when 15 is divided by 1 there's no
remainder so k
1 does not work k equals 2.
so let's actually let's just do it k
remainder one two three four five six
seven
all right it's gonna go all the way up
to fifteen
eight you know we could keep trying so
when you have a remain when one the
remainder is zero two goes into uh
fifteen seven times the remainder one
three goes into 15 with the remainder of
zero
four four goes into fifteen with a
remainder
of three
right because four
gets to twelve and then you have a
remainder of three
five has a remainder of zero
six
once again six gets to twelve and it has
a remainder of
of three
so six works so four
and six
work 7 has a remainder of 1
right
7
14 remainder of 1. and then if you just
did 8 9 10 11 12 13 eight has a
remainder well eight has a remainder of
seven
nine is a remainder of six
ten has a remainder of five eleven has a
remainder of
four right fifteen divided by eleven is
one remainder four twelve has a
remainder of three so
12 works
13 has a remainder of 2 14 has a
remainder of 1 and then 15 has no
remainder again so the numbers that work
for k are 12
6
and 4.
so it's essentially
the factors
the factors of
well
i can't actually say that well we just
did it by brute force and that those are
our those are the three k's that work
for this problem so the answer is choice
c
i'm trying to think if there's a faster
elegant way of doing this but this
actually didn't take
too much time
anyway that's that's all for this
section i'll see you in the next sat
section